u.s president joe biden has warned
russia against using chemical or nuclear
weapons in ukraine he said so in a
response to a question in a pre-recorded
cbs interview before leaving for queen
elizabeth's funeral in london
vladimir putin is becoming embarrassed
and pushed into a corner
and i wonder mr president what you would
say to him if he is considering using
chemical or tactical nuclear weapons
don't
don't don't
so what changed the face of war
unlike anything since world war ii
and the consequences of that would be
what
what would the u.s response be
do you think i would tell you if i knew
exactly what it would be of course i'm
not going to tell you
it'll be consequential they'll become
more of a pariah in the world than they
ever have been and depending on the
extent of what they do will determine
what response would occur
has more from washington
everything we've heard from the u.s
administration and intelligence
officials has been consistent over the
last
several months that the u.s has seen
absolutely no evidence that russia is
preparing for a tactical nuclear attack
in ukraine it has seen no preparations
it doesn't even feel that it's plausible
that vladimir putin would make such move
in the current circumstances in fact
there was some reporting in the new york
times that the administration officials
felt that far from being cornered there
are plenty of conventional weapons and
tactics far more brutal that putin
hasn't used yet so there's there isn't
that feeling that he's in a cornered
state there is a debate about what would
potentially make russia use its nuclear
arsenal william burns in april the cia
director said it was if russia felt it
was under an exit some sort of
existential threat he gave the example
of nato militarily getting involved on
the ground all mass
in
ukraine
that's something that the
us is trying to avoid giving the
perception of to russia that this is now
just simply an all-out proxy war between
the us and nato and and russia and
that's one of the reasons why joe biden
is refusing to give zolensky the
long-range missiles he keeps asking for
which could potentially be used against
russia that according to a lot of
reporting and sources is what joe biden
feels could be potentially a red line
where russia would suddenly feel wait
this is now an existential threat